the story of bloomers and how this
humble garment became a feminist fashion
statement women's clothing in the mid
19th century was cumbersome and heavy
sometimes weighing as much as 11 kilos
that's the same weight as a large
watermelon imagine carrying that around
all day outfits included crinolines hoop
skirts bustles bodice and tightly laced
corsets these tight uncomfy clothes
caused all kinds of health problems
including fainting squashed organs and
deformities in 1851 US activist
Elizabeth Smith Miller started wearing
loose light trousers gathered at the
ankles these were similar to turkish
trousers and were known as turkish
dresses her suffragists friend Elizabeth
Cady Stanton decided to wear some when
she visited Amelia Jenks bloomer the
publisher of the first American
newspaper for women in the US the Lilly
Amelia bloomer loved the idea of this
new liberating garment so much that she
began to wear the trousers herself and
promote them in her magazine even
publishing instructions on how to make
them the Press ended up calling this new
outfit
the bloomer dress later this was
abbreviated to simply bloom us the idea
of women wearing trousers caused outrage
at the time they were considered
strictly menswear some women were even
arrested when wearing them Amelia
bloomer said I stood amazed at the
Ferrari I had unwittingly caused some
praised and some blamed some committed
and some ridiculed and condemned
bloomers became a symbol for the women's
rights movement leading to the bloomer
dress also called the freedom dress and
Amelia herself becoming a prominent
figure in the u.s. suffragette movement
there were many styles of bloomers often
combined with dresses and they
eventually became shorter and tighter
before falling out of favor only to
reappear in the early 20th century worn
by women taking part in sports including
the craze for cycling you'd think a
woman wearing trousers would be no big
deal these days but look at how much
chatter and debate there was around
Hillary Clinton and a famous pantsuit
when she was running for US president
Amelia Jenks bloomers two legged legacy
strides on into the 21st century thanks
for watching don't forget to subscribe
and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon